the jurgen experience so tell me what
the training's been like
but what was the first day you started
mma training
i would tell you like i was having
anxiety for about a week
i couldn't sleep really i couldn't
really eat because i had signed a
contract with the pfl but i didn't have
a plan
and it was bothering me it was like what
the [ __ ]
you know something like okay where am i
training that how much training when do
i start getting ready like
was it a conversation with jon jones
that brought you to jackson michael john
um i was actually going to reach out to
them but thank god they reached out to
me
and i was like oh thank you jesus
because it was like i was going i
already had hit up john
up on um on instagram and he was being
all busy and stuff and he didn't get
back with me until i landed in
albuquerque he was like yo you're coming
to albuquerque he's like yeah i'm
pushing a hotel let you drive my car and
i'm like
dude thanks but it would've been great
to hear if you like last week
you know but he ended up helping me out
with that and um
i trained him for about like a good two
or three weeks and and johnny bones did
the first week like
watching uh kind of scoping a little bit
and it was like we just figured out that
we were twins
and that was the best thing ever because
he's a hard worker he's smart he's
strategic
and we believe in hard work and he
started drilling me like
like like the coaches would just sit on
the side and just watch us for three
four hours
and they would see like i'm full of
energy i'm like let's go what else you
got
and you know he was teaching me stuff
and uh coach wink would come in a little
bit some time coach jackson to come in
but sometimes
it would just me and johnny and they
would be just kind of
just looking at greatness from the
outside and they would never give me any
any um you know crap after but like my
like my first day
going to jackson wing gym i looked at
the cages and stuff
and i was walking to the gym to the cage
and i thought to myself i was like what
the [ __ ] am i doing here
when was the first day you grappled
first day
first day first day and that's the thing
i thought i said that in my head i'm
like jesus what am i doing here
and i said it out loud and then misha
who works with jackson lee jim he looked
at him he's like clarissa is gonna be
okay and i was like
what he was like you just said jesus
what are you doing here i'm like oh i'm
so out of my mind i thought i said it in
my head
i'm not even i'm not even i'm not even
insane right now
so that's hilarious i'm like i'm like
yeah i'm sorry i'm just so like right
i'm you know
just nervous and they're like um i think
coach jackson asked me he said what are
you most worried about and i'm like
i'm not worried about the striking the
punching or the kicking i'm not worried
about that i'm like i'm just worried
about being on the ground and not
knowing how to get up like
right i've been having nightmares about
this [ __ ] and all of a sudden he just
was like all right get on your back
that sounds like greg he's like we're
that's what we're going to start with
and he's like we're going to strengthen
your weaknesses
and also uh make it to where you can put
everything together to where it's you
and ever since that day i've just been
super comfortable i think i had one
one training judicial where i was like
man this was so hard today
we did well we did the same thing like
the next day and i was way
better and comfortable at it it's just
like being on my back
and having a fight off my back is just
it's just not what boxers do right you
know so it was like it was
uncomfortable but we had been doing
different stuff on our back but then
just this one drill
was like oh man this is stressful you
know i didn't feel like was it like
defending against ground strikes
like when you're on like when you're on
your back and someone's hitting you
well that's the thing was that weird we
had he taught me what the defense was
and he said
and you're worried about somebody
hitting you in the face but you got to
realize that they gotta they got to make
it past your feet
to then get you to the face so it's like
a lot of leg action
really is a lot of shrimps a lot of um
just keeping your feet there keeping
your hands up being being defensive
and knowing what to do when they do get
past your feet or like or like what to
do so that's my thing of like
i'm not worried about it happening i
just want to know what to do when it
when it when it does happen right like i
want to have a game plan for everything
and when they understood that they're
like you know you're a very smart
fighter
and they start teaching me and i learn
stuff really really fast i don't know
because i'm younger
or because i'm smart but well you're in
the lead athlete
and you understand your body at a very
very high level that's
i think like i said earlier about
whatever you want to do in life like
if you become an elite boxer like you
have two-time olympic gold medalist
i think you could do anything it's just
a matter of if you put the same drive
and focus and dedication that you've
done to boxing
you could apply that to anything whether
it's you want to become a dedicated
grappler
i think you could be a world-class
grappler 100
you just have to dedicate yourself yeah
exactly and that's what i'm going to do
you know i'm trying to i think i'm
supposed to fight in boxing again like
september
maybe december so this time i have here
from april to
september december it's really going to
be focused on mma so i'm putting in
putting uh putting in a time for it but
then it's still just like
just got to see how much i can consume
because sometimes someday they teach me
so much
and i'm like oh my god like like my
brain is tired
from thinking about all this but i learn
it and once i learn it i get it and i
take
so many notes in my phone yeah and i got
videos of stuff
that i have my phone so when i'm at home
i can do some of the training
and do some of the techniques just so i
can just keep it in my mind and keep it
refreshed because i understand how
important
repetitiveness is like it's super
important yeah
it is it's everything and when you're
when you're training for ground fighting
do you ever think of yourself as maybe
competing in a wrestling tournament or
jiu jitsu tournament or something like
that someday
nope i i don't look at that because
coach tucson who's my mma coach mma
judicial coach
and coach jackson and coach wink they
said the best mma fighters are the ones
who know how to mix everything up
together
so sometimes you go into just wrestling
and you start getting into wrestling
mode
and then you do just when you start
doing jiu jitsu he's like it's
you want to know how to punch and throw
your kicks
and punch and be defensive and
everything together and do judicial
stuff all with the mma style which i
feel like was
super smart and i only can say this
stuff because i asked them the same
thing
like i think i'm so competitive that
when i found out about like the color of
the belts and
just so i'm like oh i got to be black
belt
right and they're like
[Music]
not so fast like we want to teach you
jujitsu
and you to learn it but you're not going
to learn like the regular person will
learn it you're learning strictly for
mma
and so just learning that it's like
once you get more profound in mma and
you learn how to make
stuff up and you have enough to just
sort of get you
to hide when you're against high level
fighters who know this
then we can start getting you more
experience and just
but right now we want you just to do it
just to learn it
with mma style do you remember the first
time you tapped somebody out
me yeah i haven't you've never tapped
anybody out no
no so do you do just plain jiu jitsu
sparring do you roll
yeah i i i do rolling with coach tusa
which
some days it's fun and some days it is
not
because he's you know he's a black belt
i think with like triple stripes and
stuff
and i mean he doesn't take it easy you
know he's super like
i hate being grabbed so my main thing is
like oh you grab me
get off me yeah right he's like no you
want to do stuff that can advance your
movement how could you get in the
position of where you're winning in
at first my mind was completely
defensive which i'm super
super relaxed at getting people off me
like you grab me okay he touched me here
oh you touching me here okay let me get
back here
i'm on the ground he showed me this
let's work on that but
um oh i see an armbar let me try to grab
it
you know just being like that but
at first i was super defensive now i'm
like kind of
offensive with it and when we're trying
to do the whole judicial thing i'm like
man
it's still hard it's a whole different
level of breathing
um it's five minutes compared to the two
minutes that i do unboxing
right even though i sparred three
minutes but still three minutes compared
to five it's way different
but i'm just getting that cardio up
there and i'm just
having to do like the wrestling stuff
it's not
it's not easy by far but it's fun some
days it's fun and some days i'm like man
i can't wait till this hour and two
hours out of here
so are you doing any live jiu jitsu
roles with other people other than the
coach or you're just
doing it only with the coach right now
i've done some kickboxing sparring
with other fighters i haven't done
anything to jujitsu yet
but that's because of the timing too
like once we were really starting to get
into it i had a boxing match get
scheduled
and that was to me i had to make that be
more important than mma at the time
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience